Eggplant.
Grilled cheese and tomato soup from Panera.
So they like to call this cotton candy,...
...even though in England, it's called candy floss,...
...but really, cotton candy makes more sense than candy floss.
You can't floss with it, can you?
What is that?
Oh no, that stumped me.
I'm going to have to open it.
Courgette, that's courgette, isn't it?
But in America, I want to say it, but I could be wrong.
Is it zucchini?
It's zucchini.
See, I always thought zucchini was pasta.
That's a zucchini.
Next dish.
I always get confused with this.
They'd call it a cookie, wouldn't they?
But a scone they'd call a biscuit.
Actually, I'm going to have to agree with the Americans on this one.
I do say french fries.
I don't say chips unless it's fish and chips.
Then I have to say fish and chips,...
...so I'm not going to say fish and french fries.
So I'm going to have to go with the Americans again on this one.
I do say french fries.